all right joining me now for more on
this former acting attorney general Matt
Whitaker Matt you just heard Christina's
report there and I want to get your
reaction are are you surprised that
we're getting news like this not at all
Griff and it's good to be with you today
you know what I'm seeing obviously is
that we have millions of people that
have come into our country whether you
know completely illegally or whether
they have filed these bogus uh Asylum
claims that are not going be adjudicated
for up to a decade ultimately you know
the the people that want to do us harm
know that we are allowing everybody to
enter our country uh and that is causing
these situations like you saw in Houston
but what's important is that both these
cases that were just referenced that
means that law enforcement is working
I'm just concerned that they're
overwhelmed with the sheer numbers of
folk that have illegally entered our
country or have filed these bogus Asylum
claims and that there just not enough
law enforcement officers not enough ice
not enough FBI officers to do their jobs
Griff we need you've been down the
Border many times so have I we have to
shut this border down until we can get
operational control and understand who
is coming in our country and Congress
needs to act should have acted and you
know I'm just I'm kind of tired of
politicians telling us to doing
everything they can when they're doing
absolutely nothing well and you're right
I mean I did spend the the first part of
October in Eagle Pass Texas and in just
the 10 days I was there Matt there were
some nine Iranians crossed six uh
syrians three Lebanese I mean they're
coming from all over and they're special
interest aliens so they get a more
extensive vetting but in just the first
two weeks of October across the entire
Southwest border and Northwest border uh
northern border there were at least two
individuals that hit this Terr screening
data set the ter watch list if you will
and that's very concerning particularly
in light of the testimony we saw this
week from FBI director Chris Ray I think
we have a little sound about where he
looks at the concern not necessarily
just from border crossers but from
anyone in this country to carry out
attacks in light of the recent situation
in Israel and in Gaza listen
here we assess that the actions of Hamas
and its allies will serve as an
inspiration the likes of which we
haven't seen since Isis launched it so
called caliphate several years ago so
add to that in my reporting I can tell
you accurately the first 31 days of
October more than 31,000 known Goda ways
meaning they were observed seen or
detected and not brought into custody
illegal migrants Crossing between ports
of Entry that's more than a thousand a
day How likely do you think and this is
a very sobering question How likely do
you think that we have potential people
with with national security threat
terrorist attack intentions coming in
these groups but we absolutely do Griff
and even if it's one in a thousand or
even one in 10,000 that's that's that's
uh many many folks that are coming here
with the intention to do harm to the
American people and remember you know
law enforcement is needs to be diligent
but I think every American citizen at
this point in time is going to have to
pay extra attention to what's happening
in their neighborhoods and in their
communities with these folks because
again so many um you know potential
terrorists have come in both known that
are on the watch list and those that
we've didn't even know were preparing
for that and I think that's what this
Houston case really points out is that
we just we have them amongst us right
now we need to pay attention what's
going on Griff and this this
administration's failed us you're the
former attorney acting attorney general
and so it it's your Insight is important
on this my last question I only got like
10 seconds but do you think that it is
really more more a matter of when not if
that this country gets hit somehow yeah
well remember law enforcement has to get
it right I would I would immediately
pivot the FBI to address these threats
is what the first thing I would do Matt
Whitaker former acting attorney general
thank you very much for your time thanks
hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now